hi guys today we're learning about
coatings to help us out we're here with
girls who code
[Applause]
[Music]
we are here with girls who code awesome
young women who are gonna go change the
world in middle school seventy-four
percent of girls express science
technology as part of their interests
but in high school when they're choosing
colleges only 0.4 percent of girls whose
computer science as their major girls
who code is here to change that so each
of us is gonna be paired up with one of
the girls who code hi KC I'm ed I may be
a little rusty but I already know the
basics basic programming language that
is what's your name kami I can't do some
super cool coding yeah this morning I
had a lot of confidence I'm like I got
this now I'm here I'm back in the
classroom I'm terrified
hello Lika hi hello girl genius I
wouldn't go that five new Jean boy
idiots I didn't play video games as a
kid I wasn't very tech oriented HTML is
something right yeah that stands for hot
tamale mama likey I'm Keith I'm Jasmine
nice to meet you let's build yahoo.com
we're gonna be all this that's this I'm
gonna make stuff it's gonna be great
we're doing lines of code how did you
get into coding I've always been around
coding and my mom's a doctor so she
really encouraged me to get into this
you found the program and I signed up
immediately how did you get into coding
I didn't I just no yes you did
no here yes you did you're in Dakota
would you want to program a videogame oh
actually for our final projects my group
and I wish program called we're using
the programming language of Python and
why is this a thing you do you're just
doing all the work yourself you're the
Creator I like to be the Creator when
the computers rise up will they like be
more lenient on coders cuz you guys are
like creators I hope okay then I'm
hanging out with all y'all that will
happen what are we gonna be doing today
Casey you're gonna try printing the
string hello world hello world oh yeah
hello world it's the first thing coders
have to code and it's good luck the
function print will print out
what you want so it's basically like
printing but without paper ah
so if you press that green button right
there that's the tiniest button why did
they not design a bigger button but to
run the script boom hello world nailed
it
this is the computer talking to me you
know you can perceive it however you'd
like okay want to get like a giant face
in the sky that vomits cats every time
you press spacebar and I want the cats
to just bounce around and they want I'm
gonna go over now is that something we
can do in 15 minutes I'm not sure hello
nerds why want to make a variable what's
a variable sort of how in algebra
there's variables what's an algebra okay
I'm gonna do my own if name is so that
then you print Hey Baby Baby how you
look so fine my program is gonna start
what uh the variable will be ariana
grande yeah and the command is Lix
yeah it just printed using a bunch of
them let's try it I'm good at coding
what are you kidding me what could be
wrong you forgot it going oh and we got
the : yeah you got I think about your
colon both in health and programming no
input you idiot still don't understand
what we are doing
Zack who run the world
Besant as its core whole we did it thank
you for teaching me how to code I did it
you can do it don't let anyone tell you
you can't okay you got this just do it
[Applause]
saying that you do more than this yeah
you actually make yeah I'm not gonna say
you should make it if you did make it we
would put in the video right now